[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire nous allons passer une heure
avec la star des collabos log
bonjour pablo servi n'y vous êtes
ingénieur agronome docteur en sciences
chercheurs vous êtes l'auteur avec
raphaël stevens de commandes tout peut
s'effondrer petit manuel de colloques
zoologie à luzech des générations
présentes s'étaient en 2015
aujourd'hui vous publiez toujours tous
les deux aux origines de la catastrophe
aux éditions les liens qui libèrent
c'est en partenariat avec le magazine
belge imaginent demain le monde un livre
collectif dans lequel sont d'analysé 25
cause de la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons aujourd'hui par des
auteurs comme alain damasio paul jorion
geneviève azam ou nancy huston
on assimile généralement l'accolade solo
gîte termes que vous avez forgée avec
raphaël stephen swart 2015 à une sorte
de prophétisme du tout est foutu
mais c'est quoi exactement pour vous
l'accolade solo j annoncé le contraire
du tout est foutu
la coloc solo jc justement éviter cet
écueil à la fois du tout et futurs tout
est foutu et à la fois du tout et tout
va bien
et donc il ya un un sentier étroit avec
une tentative de lucidité d'explication
des catastrophes des dynamiques
d'effondrement de ce qu'est ce qui nous
arrive dans ce monde est arrivé à
cheminer sur ce chemin étroit voilà avec
des mauvaises nouvelles mais aussi en
essayant de de mobiliser de réouvrir des
futurs de voilà de d'agir voilà c'est un
numéro d'équilibriste on a été pendant
trois ans de 2015 quand c'est sorti le
livre jusqu'à 2018
il ya eu un un accueil modéré mais
plutôt bon voilà dans cette tentative de
mettre des mots sur ce qui nous arrive
de tous ces convergences de catastrophe
et en 2018 il ya eu comme une explosion
une
quand on dire un réveil d'un monstre
médiatique que laquelle a collapsed au
logis c'était le déclic je pense qu'on
peut le faire remonter à la démission de
nicolas hulot
c'était en août 2010 8 et souvenez-vous
juste après il ya eu il ya eu le rapport
du giec mais c'était pendant l'été il ya
eu des canicules aussi il ya une grosse
canicule
et puis un mois après il ya eu
extinction rébellion dans le monde
entier il ya eu les gilet jaune aussi et
on a sorti le livre une autre fin du
monde est possible mais c'était une
coïncidence et depuis san et ça n'est
pas retomber le soufflé et tout le monde
y va de son mot il ya beaucoup de
malentendus beaucoup d'irrationalité
autour de cette notion de collapse au
logis qui au départ ils étaient juste la
compréhension la plus rationnelle
possible en tout cas de scientifiques
des catastrophes des effondrements
passés présents et futurs
quand vous dites effondrement on peut
considérer qu'il peut y avoir un
effondrement de la société telle que
nous la connaissons sans pour autant que
ce soit la fin de l'espèce humaine par
exemple oui absolument il ya plusieurs
degrés d'effondrement déjà on peut
penser à l'effondrement de notre société
à plusieurs niveaux ça peut être un
effondrement économique financier ou
même plus grave politique ou sociale
donc déjà il ya une sorte d'échelle de
richter des effondrements actuellement
en libye ou en syrie on a un
effondrement très profond du pays en
union soviétique c'était plutôt un
effondrement politique dans les années
90 ans qu à cuba en argentine par
exemple en 2001 je crois que c'était un
effondrement plutôt financiers donc ça
c'est au sein de la société
après il ya des civilisations qui
s'effondre entièrement il ya beaucoup
d'exemples archéologique on peut parler
c'est une hypothèse chez les
scientifiques est actuellement de
l'extinction de l'espèce humaine
mais il ya aussi deux des effondrements
dans la biosphère ii lors des
écosystèmes des courants océaniques
d'aider des zones de pêche de forêt de
deux courants climatique etc
enfin deux phénomènes climatiques donc
des phénomènes non linéaire en fait
et du coup pour résumer on a d'un côté
la civilisation terme aux industriels on
va dire en tout cas occidentalo
occidentale au centre et on va dire qui
détruit la biosphère dans crise
d'effondrement de la civilisation et
risque d'effondrement de la biosphère
évidemment il ya incompatibilité entre
les deux et il ya des dynamiques
d'effondrement partout sachant que tout
est enfin beaucoup de choses sont
interconnectés ailier donc tout ce qu'on
a apporté avec la colle absolument c'est
d'essayer de penser les effondrements de
manière complexe de manière nuancée avec
plusieurs nuances de gris et pas de
manière blanc ou noir comme le font les
mythes hollywoodiens ou d'autres récits
que post apocalyptique et alors là
pandémique que vis de vous la mettez ou
dans le tableau
on lui a donné toutes les significations
on a dit c'est la nature qui nous envoie
un message du temps de la peste noire ou
disait que c'était dieu qui nous envoyer
un message maintenance et c'est la
nature
on ya vu une répétition générale de
l'effondrement
on ya vu aussi la répétition générale de
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour endiguer le
réchauffement climatique vous blot
service vous qu'est ce que vous voyez
vous c'est vrai que nous les humains on
a vraiment tendance à tout mettre en
récit et il faut qu'on se crée une
histoire il ya un événement qui arrive
et il faut qu'on le met en contexte on
se crée un récit donc on peut
effectivement on a attendu entendu un
peu un peu tout et son contraire
beaucoup de l'histoire sur cette
pandémie
d'un point de vue purement collapse aux
logiques c'est à dire scientifique
rationnelle ou dans les rapports qu'on
lisait les publications scientifiques
on avait déjà dans les listes de choc
systémique
il y avait pandémie clairement c'est est
ce que les scientifiques le prévoyait
enfin certains scientifiques
il y avait des signes avant coureurs
toutes les conditions étaient la
destruction de la biodiversité proximité
avec des espèces nouvelles parce que
détruit les forêts primaires
interconnexion globalisé des chaînes
d'approvisionnement des transports
tourisme etc
donc on a su qu'il y avait aussi des
scientifiques cela nous l'a su après
mais qui qui qui prévoyait déjà une
pandémie à coronavirus alors que c'est
la première pandémie à coronavirus que
l'humanité connaît et donc on a c'était
dans la liste des potentiels risques
systémiques globo il y en a d'autres
il ya des risques climatiques et des
risques de black out des risques de
pannes d'électricité ça c'est vraiment
un choc systémique très très dur pour
une société
il y en a déjà eu partiellement aux
états unis etc
mais on a enfin il y en a eu en italie
aussi je crois que c'était en 2012
ils ont mesuré et bien étudié ce cas
d'un black out géant qui parce que la
société était tellement interconnecté
s'est répandue au système internet qui a
alors fait bugger à nouveau une plus
grosse zone électrique et donc on a des
phénomènes de mega
crise en fait par là dessus sur
interconnexion lippert interconnexion
des réseaux globaux des réseaux en tout
cas humains les réseaux techniques et
donc non la classe parmi les étincelles
en fête les chocs systémiques
il y en ad'autres ça sera c'est pas la
première ça sera pas la dernière
pandémie et en plus d'autres chocs
systémiques donc on arrive dans un
siècle avec on va subir une augmentation
de la fréquence et de l'intensité des
chocs systémiques qui soit climatique
sur les ressources sur l'énergie sur le
banc géopolitique
voilà les guerres aussi les famines etc
ou les pandémies et ça fait partie des
paliers des étincelles qui sont capables
de déstructurer le système monde en tout
cas nos sociétés ça l'a été le cas ça a
été le cas alors cette pandémie on a eu
la chance qu'elle ait pas été si mortel
que ça mais on a bien vu comment la
société les pouvoirs les codes mis à
vaciller
et comment là il ya en temps de crise on
a dû opérer des des politiques nouvelles
d'adaptation voilà donc sais c'est pas
fini en fait elle n'est pas derrière
nous là on arrive avec une vague
psychiatrique on arrive avec des vagues
social avec combien hui
10 millions de pauvres en france 3 et 8
millions de français qui mangent pas à
leur faim
on arrive avec des niveaux d'inégalités
qui s'accroissent et c'est donc on n'a
pas fini de voir les conséquences de
cette pandémie et elles peuvent encore
ses conséquences déclencher d'autres
catastrophes en chaîne donc elles font
partie si les historiens du futur montre
que la période convient décide que la
période convient était finalement un
effondrement
je pense que la pandémie je joue aura
joué un rôle important et quand on lit
le livre que vous vous dites pline
publié aux origines de la catastrophe
je rappelle 25-25 causes qui sont
étudiés par des auteurs très varié il
peut y avoir des auteurs de science
fiction comme alain damasio une écrivain
comme comme dans le cius tonnes un
économiste comme paul jorion donc chacun
prend un thème mais on voit bien aussi
que là encore tout est imbriqué et parmi
les les dents les causes responsables
les plus dénoncés on peut notamment du
réchauffement climatique et de la
disparition de la biodiversité on trouve
pêle-mêle le capitalisme la finance
mondiale le néolibéralisme les
inégalités qui en découlent
est ce que ça vous semble une si grande
évidence que cela oui en fait c'est
quelque chose qui revient souvent je
sais pas si quand vous discutez avec les
les habits la famille sur sur les causes
éventuelles des de ce qu'on est en train
de vivre
chacun y va de sa petite idée en fait de
ses convictions et souvent le
capitalisme c'est une étiquette qui
revient qui revient qui est vraiment
l'adversaire le plus commun enfin
désigné comme le plus frais le plus
fréquemment et le truc c'est que le
capitalisme est aussi la conséquence
d'autres causes en fait comment là comme
l'a montré dans le livre il ya cette
séparation nature culture il ya ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'économicisme c'est à
dire le fait de voir tout de manière
économique et de deux d'oublier la
biosphère et ça inclut aussi le
communisme enfin le l'union soviétique
il ya cette volonté de puissance dont
parle d'ailleurs matthieu auzanneau
sur le chapitre des énergies fossiles
c'est cette volonté de puissance de
d'expansion et de domination qui est
vraiment très caractéristique de
l'europe c'est très european au centre
et pour reprendre le trait le très beau
livre de fabienne schadler un allemand
qui
qui s'intitule la fin de la mégamachine
il montre très bien comment la
convergence de cette volonté de
domination de dessus de d'expansion
alliée à la création des états et de la
machine militariste a créé en plus de la
dette et du monde de la finance par
exemple la gêne c'est les marchands de
gènes qui ont envoyé christophe colomb
pour rembourser les dettes et donc
l'argent du pillage des amériques a
servi à rembourser les dettes et à faire
marcher cette finance déjà européenne et
donc ça a créé une colonialisme un extra
activisme un impérialisme en fait qui
dont on est les héritiers dans le
capitalisme est l'héritier il ya aussi
on peut citer dans les causes aussi du
capitalisme qui est né dans l'angleterre
victorienne
à l'époque de darwin les philosophes ont
utilisé la pensée de darwin est une
magnifique théorie biologique pour
justifier les inégalités
pour justifier ce capitalisme prédateur
la loi du plus fort la compétition
généralisée
ils ont ils ont fait une idéologie et
voilà et tout ça s'emboîte
s'enchevêtrent est ce qu'on voulait
arriver à faire c'est c'est d'abord
invité plusieurs auteurs pour montrer
continuer cet exercice de transit plis
narith et qu'on avait enfin qui comment
dire qui est présent dans tous nos
livres et en plus sortir de la science
inviter des auteurs des voix la
dramaturge romancier pour montrer que
c'est pas qu'une question technique et
scientifique et en même temps toutes ces
causes sur la table déjà créé un effet
whaou
en fait il y en a beaucoup elles sont
toutes plus ou moins crédibles
il y en a même d'autres on pourrait en
rajouter d'autres et j'invite les
lecteurs vraiment à ça pour en rajouter
aussi et puis inviter le lecteur à
tisser c'est vraiment intéressant moi
j'ai essayé avec ses 25 cause en les
mettant sur la table de faire des liens
de cause à effet plus - des boucles de
rétroaction et de me faire une
arborescence est en fait à chaque fois
que je refais un schéma il est un
différents et voilà et donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un écueil un risque c'est que
finalement ce faua vent soit dépassé par
tout ça et on se dise bon qu'est-ce
qu'on fait finalement parce que si on
reprend la cause de l'invention de
l'agriculture où j'espère malades et là
les religions les mythes même le
néocortex le cortex préfrontal le la
thermodynamique les sociétés complet
qu'on peut on peut se dire on est
dépassé par tout ça on se sent
impuissant
mais d'un autre côté ça permet aussi de
rassembler d'associer les luttes on a
dans le même livre
un chapitre assez chouette d'ailleurs
sur le patriarcat et ça rejoint les donc
le combat échos fait ministre qui peut
rejoindre le cap hit enfin le combat
anticapitaliste la lutte contre la
finance débridée et c'est donc on peut
aussi grâce à ce bouquin en tout cas je
l'espère c'était l'hypothèse de départ
associée des luttes et faire converger
un petit peu des mouvements quoi pour
dire c'est à l'action on peut en ajouter
d'autres on peut aussi mettre toutes les
tendances à l'oeuvre actuellement tous
les tous les ismes à la mode donc
pourrait les mettre dans dancing on peut
aussi en retrancher
c'est plus facile de retrancher parce
qu'au fond d'accuser le capitalisme la
finance les inégalités des inégalités
existait avant le capitalisme elle était
même encore plus forte avant le
capitalisme ça s'appelait la féodalité
s'était pas capitaliste mais c'était
très inégalitaire on pourrait dire que
si le communisme avait triomphé il
aurait continué de nous de massacrer la
biodiversité ou de houe de réchauffer
l'atmosphère
à l'égal du capitalisme au fond ski ski
soit qu'on pourrait réduire tout ça
c'est l'accumulation de richesses c'est
à force d'accumuler des richesses et si
le communisme avait été capable d'en
accumuler autant que le capitalisme il
aurait autant polluer autant massacrer
la biodiversité autant réchauffer
l'atmosphère que ne l'a fait le
capitalisme c'est donc l'accumulation de
richesses au fond le problème assez
intéressant reste donc c'est votre
analyse mais effectivement c'est un
certain point clé là ce que j'appelais
tout à l'heure la volonté de puissance
la volonté de domination se traduit
aussi par une
en tout cas en europe comme par une
volonté d'accumulation infini du capital
mais aussi de ressources et c'est une
des causes majeures en lien aussi avec
la création des états et de l'appareil
militaire qui qui qui crée le bras armé
de la puissance de domination
donc on en vient effectivement et votre
remarque est juste c'est-à-dire accusé
juste le capitalisme ça crée des angles
morts et par exemple il ya le vin
l'union soviétique mais d'autres
idéologies ou aussi d
des graves défauts et est donc en
mettant toutes ces causes comment dire
en les tice en ensemble on voit bien
qu'il n'a pas qu'une et que est
d'arriver à dégager les angles morts ça
permet de voilà de prendre du recul
après l'exercice dont je parlais de
tisser on peut aussi essayer de
déclasser alors moi j'ai fait l'exercice
de les regrouper
donc dans le livre en fait on les classe
par temporalité et ainsi on retrouve
comment dire une histoire de l'ue de
l'humanité est un récit c'est un récit
en fait une linéarité dans ses causes
c'est un choix éditorial
ceci dit moi je me suis amusé à les
classer en deux catégories différentes
et qu'est ce qui ressort pour moi c'est
si mes souvenirs sont bons il ya la
séparation nature culture qu'est
majeures qui regroupe plein d'autres
choses comme eh ben la perte du sauvage
la création des villes de l'urbain le
techno cocon comme dirait alain damasio
toutes ces appendices technique qui nous
empêche finalement d'être sensible par
rapport au monde vivant et qui nous
maintiennent dans un dans un cocon
technique ou virtuels aussi finalement
nous empêche de nous adapter et d'être
en lien avec le vivant bref il y en a il
y en a quelques-unes je vais pas toutes
les citer et puis à d'un autre côté une
sorte de deux groupes qui comment je
l'avais appelé ça c'était ouais c'était
la volonté de puissance et
d'accumulation et là on retrouve tous
les ismes comme vous disiez
extractiviste impérialisme capitalisme
ont même le patriarcat aussi c'est la
domination contre les pauvres contre les
femmes contre les animaux contre les
contre les autres peuples et les autres
cultures avec le colonialisme et
finalement tout c'est toute cette
volonté d'accumulation de puissance
elle débouche sur des inégalités une
surpopulation des états très fort et
tout ça sont des verrous vous parlez
dans le premier livre de verrouillage
sociotechniques déverrouillage juridique
déverrouillage psychologique
déverrouillage institutionnel qui
empêche toute transition vous souvenez
la métaphore dans le premier livre en
2015 c'était celle d'une voiture est
actuellement on va pas à foncer vers un
mur on est plutôt sorti de la route
ça c'est le climat et la biodiversité on
dévale dans le brouillard une pente
plein d'obstacles
on appuie à fond sur la c'est là
besoin de croissance illimitée
le réservoir est vide en tout cas ça
clignote et c'est sur la réserve et le
conducteur est fou comme drogués par la
croissance il veut accélérer mais
surtout souvenez-vous le volant est
bloqué c'était ça les verrouillages à
l'époque et on les as et verrouillage
les états par exemple aujourd'hui c'est
ça le grand paradoxe qu'on n'arrive pas
à démêler les états sont à la fois des
adversaires et des alliés en france
c'est très clair aujourd'hui l'état qui
passe des lois sécuritaires comme on le
voit aujourd'hui
quirky retrouve sa puissance en fait
deux comment dire avec des dérives
autoritaristes et en même temps un état
qui peut être un outil de coordination
d'une transition vers par exemple la fin
des énergies fossiles ou peu importe les
objectifs qu'on se trace aussi audacieux
soit-il vers un monde durable soutenable
en lien avec le vivant c'est un état
garant coordinateur qu'on pourrait
inventer qu'on pourrait construire un
état qui favorise les initiatives
locales qui favorise la créativité
l'innovation politique on pourrait rêver
de cette structure
parce que maintenant il est temps
d'aller vite et à grande échelle et
l'état est à la fois voilà impossible
outils mais à la fois un risque très
fort et on on voit bien aussi en sachant
que depuis 500 ans l'état
c'est ça a été comment dire le pas le
frère jumeau mais l'allié du capitalisme
sans état il n'y a pas de capitalistes
possible c'est le bras armé du
capitalisme donc l'état ça une histoire
de 500 ans de violence même plus de
destruction des pubs de création les
hiérarchies et c'est donc on a un
paradoxe là en ce moment qui pour moi
est un verrou comment on crée du
politique aujourd'hui mais c'est une
question ouverte je vous la pose sans
l'état aujourd'hui il a capté tout
l'imaginaire instituant il est il et il
a le monopole en fait du lien social de
la de l'institution et et c'est vraiment
très très dur pour ceux qui veulent
réinventer des manières de faire de la
politique de faire sans l'état et on
doit faire à la fois avec à la fois sans
c'est ça le paradoxe mais on peut dire
aussi que le capitalisme et aider là où
l'état était faible dans la république
comme venise ou kogen en flandre là où
il ya juste eu ce bon la féodalité était
faible le l'état était faible mais bon
c'est un autre débat
on est d'accord que l'accumulation de
richesses n'est pas propre au
capitalisme ça préexistait au
capitalisme et ça pourrait continuer
d'exister alors même que le capitalisme
a disparu l'accumulation de richesses au
fond ça commence comme jean-paul de
boules le dit dans votre livre célèbre
archéologue qui était à votre place ya
pas si longtemps d'ailleurs
l'accumulation de richesses ça commence
quand on se sédentarisent quand on
arrête d'être dehors des chasseurs de
cueilleurs d'art est d'être des nomades
et à partir de ce moment là on peut
commencer à accumuler des richesses
on peut inventer l'agriculture on peut
inventer la propriété privée inventé les
chefs les religions les guerres tout ça
vient avec la sédentarisation et on va
accumuler des richesses au sein des
empires des villes des villages des
tribus avec le colonialisme mais aussi
sans le colonialisme en envahissant le
voisin ou en en confisquant le champ d'à
côté en faisant des esclaves ou en
inventant le travail le salariat tout ça
va venir
de la même façon on peut dire
effectivement que s'il ya un moment où
s'il fallait revenir en arrière
ce serait vraisemblablement avant le
néolithique
c'est à dire devenir des chasseurs
cueilleurs parce que c'est aussi
l'accumulation de richesses et la
sédentarisation qui a fait l'explosion
démographique si nous sommes 7 milliards
aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous avons
été un milliard à un moment et pour
pouvoir devenir un milliard il fallait
se sédentariser ouais sortir des
énergies fossiles qui nous ont permis
cette explosion effectivement mais dans
dans votre récit qui est qui est très
bien été documentés par james cott
partout ces anthropologues anarchiste
qui montre que les chats et je pense
aussi à marshall salines ce qu'ils
disaient que les sociétés disons de
chasseurs cueilleurs travailler moins
ils vivaient mieux en fait en meilleure
santé
et après quand certains sont
sédentarisés le l'étude des eaux est
dédé comment dire des squelettes des
premiers agriculteurs montré qu'en fait
il avait vraiment des déformations une
vie très dure et caetera et que des bus
par sédentarisation au début c'est sa
voix la galerie d est en ouest est ça l
est en fait le blé au ciment qui montre
comment l'agriculture est en tout cas le
choix du blé à être enfin des céréales a
été fait pour conter en fait les
récoltes les stocker et du coup
invention de l'agriculture des scribes
de la comptabilité de l'armée pour
garder les stocks etc
ceci dit dans ce récit je pense qu'il
faut
éviter l'écueil de la linéarité du
déterminisme fin de l'obligation de
passer par tout ça je pense c'est le
alors j'ai comment dire les travaux de
l'anthropologue david gréber qui
malheureusement est décédé récemment et
de son collègue donc j'ai oublié le nom
qui était en train d'écrire justement un
livre j'espère qu'ils vont réussir à le
sortir sur le fait qu'il y a eu aussi
des grandes sociétés dont on a moins de
traces mais les anthropologues commence
à en trouver moins hiérarchiques moins
inégalitaire parce qu'il ya une sorte de
règle qui veut que plus les sociétés
grandissent en complexité plus elles
deviennent hiérarchique plus il ya des
inégalités c'est structurel alors c'est
structurel aujourd'hui mais ça n'a pas
toujours été et et c'était tout le
travail de ces nouveaux archéologues
d'arrivée a montré qu'on pouvait faire
des grandes sociétés aussi de type plus
horizontale moins hiérarchiques moins
inégalitaire et ça ça ça redonne un peu
d'air frais sa ré ouvre une brèche dans
notre imaginaire parce que vous entendez
dire revenir dos au passé effectivement
on pourrait se dire si une des causes
c'est l'invention de l'agriculture
comment est ce qu'on fait pour revenir
avant l'invention de l'agriculture ok on
va devenir chasseur cueilleur mais ça
veut dire quoi concrètement mais ya pas
assez de forêt on est sept milliards
donc là il ya un verrou dans lequel on
est coincé et vous interrompt alors
pensé je vous interromps pour ça ce
verrou pub le service nous on fait juste
une pause ça nous donne le temps d'y
réfléchir et on se retrouve juste après
je vous offrirai
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous a filmé un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco
maintenant c'est l'industrie qui gagne
mais du coup peut-être que ce qui va
rester c'est que les films qui seront de
plus en plus fait pour le cinéma et pas
sur les grands réseaux resteront des
objets artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma on
lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
on reprend cette émission avec tableaux
servi n'y est le livre qu'il vient de
publier avec raphaël stevens aux
origines de la catastrophe
parmi les raisons invoquées on parle
beaucoup de la croissance de la
production et on en arrive toujours aux
accumulation de richesses mais mais la
croissance la production on sait que au
fond c'est un problème d'énergie c'est
lui l'énergie utilisée qui pose problème
ça n'est ni la croissance ni la
production par exemple pourrait imaginer
que si on utilisait que de l'énergie
nucléaire pour produire tout ce que l'on
produit
on n'aurait pas le problème de
réchauffement climatique qu'on a
aujourd'hui
et de ce fait à chaque fois qu'on ferme
une une centrale nucléaire aujourd'hui
un pays comme la france et d'un on
augmente nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par mais la même occasion
donc est ce que on doit balayer les
problèmes de production les problèmes de
productivisme les problèmes de
croissance
parce que au fond ça n'est pas le
problème balayés je pense pas mais c'est
vrai que c'est une question d'énergie on
l'oublié trop souvent là le chapitre de
matthieu auzanneau montre bien que les
énergies fossiles c'est le sait le noeud
du problème
parce que si on retire les énergies
fossiles même avec le nucléaire on
arrivera où les énergies renouvelables
on n'a pas la capacité de remplacer
cette puissance en terme de joules c'est
pas possible et même le nucléaire c'est
quelque chose de deux fini il ya des
stocks d'uranium fini à des stocks
voilà deux
de minerai et le nucléaire nécessite
aussi pas mal d'ingénieurs de béton
d'armé de de conquête vers les
militaires en tout cas vers des
territoires avec des minerais bref tout
ça effectivement ailier ce qu'on me
disait un appareil de production
tentaculaire un ogre en fait qu'ils
mangent de plus en plus et qui enfin et
qu'ailier comment dire au fond à cette
volonté de puissance et d'accumulation
et là il ya un goulot d'étranglement
serre que les énergies à un moment enfin
c'est l'énergie que c'est là quand c'est
le mouvement en fait la quantité de
mouvement là on déplace des objets on se
déplace la quantité le la quantité
d'énergie qu'on brûle elle est liée au
pib
si on brûle moins d'énergie le pib
diminue voilà c'est tout simple c'est
physique et un moment on a n'aura pas
assez d'énergie pour maintenir une
croissance économique donc mais un
goulot d'étranglement avec une
croissance qui va s'arrêter bientôt
qu'on le veuille ou non donc l'idée
d'une transition c'est d'anticiper cette
grande descente énergétique espace la
plus le plus doucement pacifiquement
possible ce qui m'apparaît quand même
compliqué mais sa vigne or rien ne nous
oblige à la décroissance que vous que
vous annoncez si ce n'est si on a un
problème d'énergie
le problème c'est l'énergie ça n'est pas
la croissance s'y retrouvent demain si
on réussit transition énergétique vers
une énergie totalement propre on pourra
multiplier la croissance par 12,6 tenté
qu'on est capable parce que si vous
regardez bien la croissance elle et elle
est stagnante depuis maintenant 40 ans
donc on y est habitué à ce que la troupe
croissance stagne
c est vers gérante en cas les énergies
fossiles non mais imaginons ont fait
long feu louis hénon ont fait l'exercice
faisons l'exercice comment dire d'un
exercice de pensée une expérience de
pensée
imaginons qu'on trouve une pilule de
l'énergie infinie c'est quand comme dans
le roman de barjavel la nuit d alan il
ya plus besoin de pétrole ya plus besoin
nucléaire voilà on a une énergie infinie
est-ce que ça va résoudre pour autant
léser les problèmes des espèces
disparues est ce que ça va
résoudre imaginons on doit quand même se
déplacer donc il faut des routes des
pneus comment on fait pour pour le
problème les matériaux ne serait ce que
la danse quelque chose de beaucoup plus
concret la voiture électrique
on a juste déplacer la pollution pour
créer ou la voiture enfin comment dire
il faut quand même du lithium il faut
quand même des terres rares il faut
quand même de du métal
on a vu récemment je crois que s'il ya
deux jours que ce qui pollue énormément
dans les villes s'étaient pas seulement
les particules fines en suspension
c'était les particules oxydantes dont
les les
comment dire l'usure des pneus et des
freins mais que ce soit électrique ou
thermique
il ya toujours des pneus et des freins
dans une voiture donc c'est pareil un
autre exemple le virtuel on parle de
découplage c'est à dire de créer une
croissance qui soit plus dans le
matériel mais dans le virtuel
seulement le virtuel c'est quand même
des serveurs de l'électricité des
technologies de pointe
skype des terres rares etc et des câbles
en cuivre qui traverse l'atlantique
voilà c'est quand même aussi une
croissance matérielle en tout cas c'est
des bases matérielles et on n'a pas
réussi pour l'instant à dématérialiser
cette croissance ceci dit effectivement
je vous suis dans le sens où on pourrait
imaginer une croissance de la santé et
du mieux-être en tout cas de la joie de
vivre je ne sais pas moi de la
convivialité
d'autres choses que la croissance juste
matériel ou économique et là oui là je
vous suis complètement en tout cas on
pourrait imaginer une croissance propre
il ya aussi qui revient constamment
notamment dans votre livre chez
plusieurs auteurs il ya les riches les
riches sont très souvent accusée d'être
à l'origine de la catastrophe
alors ça va être soit les ultra-riches
les 1 % de l'humanité qui serait
responsable de deux fois plus
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre que
la moitié la plus pauvre l'humanité à 1%
seulement c'est oxfam qui a calculé ça
donc 77 millions de gens sur terre
auray serait responsable de deux fois
plus d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
soit 15% des émissions que 50 % la plus
que la moitié la plus pauvre l'humanité
alors je ne sais pas comment ils ont
calculé ça je sais même pas si c'est
possible de faire le tri dans un pays
comme la france entre les 1% les plus
riches qui consomment comme carb face
qu'il envoie comme carbone de tous les
autres enfin admettons
ça n'empêche qu'il reste quand même
après ça 85 % d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui ne sont pas dues aux ultras
risques qui sont dues être tous les
autres est ce que au fond de tout ça
plutôt que d'accuser les riches les
ultra-riches les se dire simplement que
c'est la démographie qui est un problème
et certains disent d'ailleurs c'est à
dire au fait qu'on est de plus en plus
nombreux et que le mode de vie des
riches s'est démocratisée c'est à dire
s'il n'y avait que les riches se serait
pas un problème le problème c'est que
tout ça s'est démocratisée il n'y a pas
que les riches qui ont des voitures il
ya pas que les riches qui ont des
ordinateurs n'y a pas que les riches qui
change de vêtements
il n'y a pas que les riches qui mangent
de la viande
et au fond c'est le fait qu'on ait de
plus en plus nombreux à faire tout ça
qui pose problème c'est la démographie
oui mais on peut pas on peut pas séparer
la démographie de la consommation de la
richesse le problème c'est pas qui est
trop de monde au trot driessche ces cas
où les riches c'est qu'il ya trop de
riches
c'est entre autres ils font comme butin
riche fait un enfant
oui mais quand un riche fait un enfant
ils veulent cet enfant va consommer
beaucoup plus que l'enfant d'un pauvre
en terme d'empreinte écologique
donc on ne peut pas séparer les deux
l'argument de la surpopulation il
revient souvent
aujourd'hui hélas c'est un sacré verrou
parce que comment on fait pour diminuer
la population
je vois pas de solution politique
actuellement à l'horizon ceci dit je
reviens sur la question des riches parce
que ça m'avait marqué à l'époque ce riz
ce livre d'hervé kempf je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez vous et comment les
riches détruisent la planète et montrer
ce n'était pas seulement le fait que les
riches consomment plus effectivement
voilà c'est on peut calculer ça mais
c'est le fait que les riches en
augmentant les inégalités créer un
modèle de société que les moyens riches
veulent imiter les moyens riches veulent
être imité par les moyens pauvres et les
moyens pauvres par les très pauvres et
donc à une pyramide inégalitaire
économique extrêmement élevé qui
accélère que le sociologue thorstein
veblen avait avait montré avait nommé la
consommation ostentatoire serre que les
gens se mettent à consommer des
portables des voitures des motos des
yachts et c'est pour ressembler à la
classe juste au dessus et en fait en
créant des super riches ont créé un
ultra un modèle qui va favoriser tous
ces tourbillons de consommation
équivalent qui va finalement consommée
la planète juste parce qu'on a envie de
ressembler à la classe sociale qui est
juste au dessus et voilà c'est ça qui
est
comment dire j'ai à dire criminel mais
c'est un mot trop fort mais c'est ça
c'est ça le problème des ultra riches et
en fait il ya on a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle l'entrée de l'autre loi de la
jungle avec gauthier chapelle est aussi
biologiste et on a décortiqué toutes ces
études absolument passionnante sur les
humains les expériences économiques qui
montrent bien que l'or dans une société
il ya toujours eu des inégalités le
problème c'est que quand il ya des
faibles niveaux d'inégalités ça va
encore il ya une sorte de cohésion
sociale mais quand les inégalités
augmentent
il ya une perte de cohésion sociale
parce que en fait il ya un sentiment
d'injustice
c'est pas juste lui la plus c'est pas
juste on se comprend plus en fait
et les gens ne se parlent plus et
surtout quand on voit qu'en quand les
riches arrête de se cacher en fait et on
voit le niveau de vie des riches
ça crée un sentiment de leur sentiment
de colère et du coup de désengagement
envers le bien commun c'est à dire que
les gens comme ils voient que c'est
injuste
ils veulent plus participer payer des
impôts participer au bien commun etc
et du coup on a une corrosion de la
société par ces niveaux d'inégalités
l'inégalité est extrêmement corrosif
pour les sociétés et donc voilà on peut
pointer évidemment les riches on a tous
besoin d'un bouc émissaire mais c'est
vraiment pour moi ce qui est plus
important c'est de revenir à la cause
comment se fabriquent les riches
comment se fabriquent les richesses et
les inégalités par des processus
mais comme le montrait thomas piketty
dans ses travaux le capitalisme
structurellement créer des sociétés
inégalitaires et à chaque fois qu'il ya
eu réduction des inégalités c'est qu'il
ya une grande catastrophe la crise de 29
les crises les guerres mondiales et
c'est quand la finance c'est le
capitalisme était à genoux
là les institutions ont pu les maintenir
à genoux elle est forcée à
à instituer plus d'égalité plus de moins
d'injustice en tout cas donc il ya
vraiment structurellement quelque chose
à revoir dans ses 500 ans d'histoire de
du capitalisme prédateur de cette
volonté d'accumulation il ya vraiment un
travail à faire non seulement un rapport
de force est en conquis sociaux mais
c'est pas assez c'est un travail
intérieur c'est pour ça que notre livre
je trouve il montre bien que avec ses 25
cause on voit bien comment sont
entremêlées des solutions politiques
on va dire extérieur d'organisation
sociale etc et des solutions intérieures
de rapports au monde comment on change
de rapports au monde
comanche comment on fait taire en nous
cette volonté d'accumulation infinie
comment est-ce qu'on retrouve un peu de
sagesse
comment est-ce qu'on retrouve un rapport
au monde apaisé avec le vivant non pas
en les considérant comme des objets des
ressources mais comme des sujets avec
des relations d'empathie etc etc etc
donc il ya vraiment une voix intérieure
psychologique métaphysique spirituel
spirituel dans le sens qui est j'ai
envie d'être qu'elle j'ai envie de
donner au monde quel est mon horizon ne
sera juste des questions connais toi toi
même c'est une question spirituelle je
parle pas de religion et ça c'est ce
qu'on voulait dire dans notre livre en
2018 une autre fin du monde est possible
est aujourd'hui à vraiment chantiers
politiques pour arriver à à coupler
j'allais dire ce chemin intérieur dont
on a besoin et ce chemin politique dont
on a aussi besoin on peut pas faire l'un
sans l'autre et en fait c'est un livre
aussi qui participe de cette
réconciliation c'est un peu un slogan
entre méditant et militants et on a
juste besoin d'arrêter de
de se sur la gueule quoi de
travailler ensemble une voix intérieure
permet d'enrichir les luttes politiques
et inversément
on l'a très bien vu notre dame des
landes c'était une expérience de
créativité d'innovation politique où ils
ont même pu expérimenter un autre
rapport au monde un autre rapport au
collectif à notre rapport à soi là
c'était vraiment c'est ça dont on a
besoin des zones d'expérimentation
d'innovation sociale et politique et
peut-être même farfelues on s'en fout
mais il faut créer quelque chose de
nouveau dans tous les sens plein de
mauvaises herbes partout pour pouvoir
avoir une chance de recréer une forêt de
régénérer une société il faut avoir le
plus de chances possibles de jeunes
boutures de jeunes pousses qui innovent
en fait je voudrais pas faire le
défenseur du capitalisme mais il est
tellement accusé de tous les maux que ça
m'amuse les inégalités étaient bien plus
grande avant le capitalisme que depuis
la naissance du capitalisme
le jeu n'est pas le le le sultan robe en
inde étaient vingt fois plus riche que
louis xiv il n'y avait pas le
capitalisme
en inde les roulants mais là on est
lassé des guerres fois les inégalités
avant le capitalisme était bien plus
grande que depuis le capitalisme mais
c'est un détail
les gens pensent qu'aujourd'hui
surprenait la fortune des riches
ça pourrait rembourser les dettes des
états c'est faux les états dépensent
beaucoup plus que les riffs sont
beaucoup plus riches que les riches même
si oxfam
trouve à a calculé que celle inverse non
les états sont bien plus riches que les
capitalistes mais c'est un détail
revenons à la rupture avec la nature qui
est que vous avez soulevés qui est un
des points les plus importants aussi con
peuvent remonter d'ailleurs à 1
là aussi à au néolithique
c'est là que que la destruction de la
nature commence au fond c'est quand on
commence à cultiver donc a marqué la
planète est là à la modifier
c'est là que les virus commence à
circuler aussi puisque c'est là qu'on se
range trouve au contact des bêtes qu'on
vit avec les animaux etc etc
cette rupture avec la nature qui n'a
jamais cessé qui là aussi est une des
conséquences de la démographie
plus on est nombreux plus il est logique
que la nature subissent notre poids
notre présence notre nombre j'espère pas
forcément je pense que c'est ce que je
voulais dire aussi tout à l'heure quand
il ya eu la pause c'était que l'idée
c'est pas forcément de revenir en
arrière à une société de chasseurs
cueilleurs primitiviste de dudu sauvage
idéal en pagne et cbc
c'est d'arriver à en comprenant ses
causes à voir ce qu'on peut retirer
aujourd'hui dans l'état des lieux de la
plaie l'état de la planète
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait comment on
pourrait s'inspirer de ces modes de vie
chasseurs cueilleurs de voilà alors
c'est exactement ce que font les
permaculture savez en permaculture il ya
des principes de design et des principes
éthiques
ces principes de design ils sont deux
ils sont il ya douze principes ça c'est
facile à trouver sur internet vous
verrez ces douze principes c'est quoi
sinon des principes du vivant comment
fonctionne le vivant comment le vivent
une fois qu'on applique ces principes
créer des systèmes tout à fait résidents
qui créent de l'abondance et c'est par
exemple un principe c'est créer des
cycles au lieu d'un processus linéaire
on a besoin de ressources et qui crée de
la pollution eh ben on ferme les cycles
et tout comment dire tout déchet est une
ressource pour un autre être vivant
autrement dit en forêt je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué il ya plein d'être
vivant et il n'y a pas de déchets n'y a
pas de déchets en forêt tout se recycle
s'est essayé à l'un des écosystèmes les
plus productifs au monde en termes de
biomasse et ya pas de production déchets
est capable voilà et en plus ça
fonctionne juste au solaire un exemple
un autre exemple en permaculture c'est
de dire quand vous avez un potager c'est
pas qu'il ya trop de limaces c'est qu'il
ya pas assez de canard vous fermez un
cycle et donc les canards manger limaces
et c'est donc si on applique ça c'est un
exemple pour montrer que si on applique
ces principes du vivant les systèmes
tous les systèmes que ce soit humain
dans l'entreprise dans le potager pour
la construction d'un habitat fonctionne
beaucoup beaucoup mieux sont plus
soutenables
etc etc comment on fait les créateurs de
la permaculture donc david holmgren et
bill mollison sont des australiens ils
ont été voir en fait les sociétés
première les peuples premiers qui
vivaient plus ou moins en équilibre avec
la nature
en tout cas qui ont duré dont la société
a duré vraiment longtemps qu'ils ont
vraiment comment dire passer l'examen en
fait de la durabilité parce que voilà
c'est une société qui s'est pas effondré
en tout cas qui a duré longtemps et
qu'elles étaient les caractéristiques de
ces sociétés et donc ils en ont tiré des
principes éthiques et des principes de
permaculture qui sont en fait des
principes qu'on cac a trouvé le vivant
en fait qu'à développer ployer le vivant
depuis 4 milliards d'années pour rester
juste sur terre et créer un habitat sain
donc si déjà on s'inspirait c'est pas un
retour au passé c'est vraiment un retour
vers le futur commence ainsi il trouve
le meilleur de chaque société de chaque
culture des peuples animiste de même de
notre civilisation mais je suis pas pour
rejeter la modernité ou où tous les
ismes qu'on a vu
où toutes les causes à la poubelle et
faire table rase et inventer quelque
chose de nouveau mais c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on a deux d'intéressant qu'est-ce
qu'on peut reprendre comment on peut
retisser reconstruire au bricoler et
comment on peut réécrire des horizons
aujourd'hui dans les ruines du monde va
vivre dans les ruines du capitalisme
aujourd'hui comment faire pour régénérer
le vivant et vivre bien en tout cas
dignement dans les ruines du capitalisme
voilà l'horizon de notre génération il
ya un tas de choses à faire là dedans il
établit serving le temps nous est compté
si l'on en croit les les collabos log on
va dire et bon nombre de scientifiques
qui nous prévoit un réchauffement bien
au-delà de ce que de ce que l'on
pourrait redouter
donc si le temps nous est compté que
préconisez vous j'ai l'impression que
sofia gouvernement autoritaire et un
gouvernement autoritaire mondiale parce
que si c'est juste ici ou là ça ne sert
à rien il faut qu'il ya un gouvernement
autoritaire mondiale seul un
gouvernement autoritaire mondiale peut
faire qu'on va moins consommer moins
brûlé d'énergies fossiles - - - - ça ou
le terrorisme limites parce que ça
vaudrait la peine pour sauver l'humanité
certains pourraient se persuader que le
terrorisme est nécessaire et salutaire
et en ce sens on en revient à la
pandémie on a vu ce que des
gouvernements soudain devenu autoritaire
puisqu'ils nous ont enfermés chez nous
était capable de produire pour un état
d'urgence sanitaire alors un état
d'urgence climatique
on imagine est-ce que vous en êtes ce
que vous vous dites le matin ou quand
vous vous endormez le soir peut-être
qu'il n'y a que ça qui peut nous sauver
que tout ça ça vaudrait le coup
non je pense plutôt le contraire je
pense que c'est ça qui va nous
c'est ça qui va nous perdre en fait je
pense que le retour d autoritarisme ou
des fascismes ou des gouvernements
autoritaires comme on le voit dans
beaucoup de pays aujourd'hui soit au
brésil en hongrie etc
même aux états unis avec trump c'était
comment dire
c'est un des stades de l'effondrement
d'un effondrement les autoritarismes
kankankan tout quand tout va mal quand
il ya quand il ya du bazar et du chaos
beaucoup de gens enfin dans la
population en appel à la figure du père
la figure 2 2 ce qui va ordonner même
être de l'ordre de manière autoritaire
et ça crée des régimes qui précipite les
catastrophes
ce qui crée des guerres d enfin voilà
des massacres et qui font des décisions
comment dire rapide et et brutal c'est
un grand risque en fait aujourd'hui que
l'on coupe parce qu'il ya urgence
ceci dit moi je pense enfin dans mon
rêve j'en suis dans mes rêves les plus
fous pour reprendre votre expression
quand je m'endors le soir quand je me
réveille le matin
moi c'est plutôt l'inversé c'est à dire
moi je rêve d'un effectivement d'un d'un
d'institutions garante qu'ils puissent
coordonner à la plus grande échelle
possible peut-être les états peut-être
moins je sais pas mais je rêve surtout
qu'ils coordonnent quoi des initiatives
locales qui soit vraiment ancrée dans un
territoire dans une région avec une
culture et qui déploie comme ge et à
l'heure des jeunes pousses des de
l'innovation agroécologiques peu importe
sociale politique ça soit foisonnant en
fait et pour ça on a besoin de les
laisser faire pas seulement de les
laisser faire mais aussi de les soutenir
que l'état ou en tout cas les
institutions soient des pépinières de
cette innovation de ces deux voilà on a
besoin d'audace on a besoin de gens qui
crée un nouveau monde qui ouvre des
horizons qui invente des futurs on a
besoin d'auteurs d'anticipation et de
science fiction qui osent créer des
récits des récits qui donne envie de
vivre la suite mais aussi de politiciens
voilà deux voilà d'intelligence
collective du collective etc et donc on
n'a pas besoin d'un état fort qui arrive
avec la matraque mais plutôt garant qui
soutiennent des initiatives locales
c'est pas du tout la culture aujourd'hui
en france avec cette cinquième
république monarchique pyramidale
qui voit là qu'il ya des écueils énorme
mais peut-être ça pourrait l'être moi
c'est ça dont je rêve mais c'est vrai
que actuellement entre choisir le
capitalisme vert ou le fascisme vert
voit c'est la peste ou le choléra pour
prendre un mauvais jeu de mots donc ça
ça c'est vraiment les deux grands
risques de notre époque
et là moi j'aime beaucoup la pensée
d'ivan illitch en tout cas toute cette
filiation de schumaker souvenez ce mal
is beautiful dans les années 70 ivan
illitch et là on a un magnifique texte
de thierry paquot à la fin le dernier
texte sur la démesure mais montre bien
et j'aime bien cette filiation
intellectuelle que tous les problèmes
viennent des questions de taille s'il ya
un problème quelque part ces quelques
c'est que quelque chose est trop grand
et trop gros c'est qu'on a dépassé
on a transgressé voilà une taille
optimale et aujourd'hui nos sociétés
sont boursouflés tout doit être trop
grand plus grand plus vite etc voilà et
je pense qu'on a dépassé un seuil de
convivialité comme disait ivan illitch
on n'est plus dans des sociétés
conviviale à taille humaine maîtrisable
autolimitée comme disait le philosophe
castoriadis la base de la liberté de la
responsabilité de la démocratie c'est
quoi ces l'autolimitation tant qu'on
n'aura pas une capacité individuelle et
collective à s'autolimiter n'arrivera à
rien et surtout pas de la démocratie
donc on sera vraiment soumis aux forces
du capitalisme vert ou de
l'autoritarisme verts et ee jean revient
en dernier exemple si vous me permettez
si j'ai 36 20 secondes où la seconde 20
secondes
bon mais j'en resterai là mais c'est
juste parler du rationnement en fait le
rationnement c'est une mesure politique
qui empêche les riches de surconsommer
et qui garantit le minimum vital pour
les pauvres le rationnement ce qui est
plus rationnelle etc
la grande question de notre de notre
époque c'est le partage
comment on arrivera à partager un enfant
de 6 ans arrive à 7 à cette question
c'est le partage est une chose le
rationnement 7 autoritaire vous me
l'accorderez ça rappelle pas laisser le
gros défaut mais c'est quand même le
grand alors ainsi en angleterre oui en
angleterre il ya un bon souvenir du
rationnement ils ont bien vécu ça en
france on l'a mal vécu mais
rationnellement c'est la politique la
plus juste pour des ressources limitées
si vous demandez aux anglais le
rationnement en angleterre a duré très
longtemps après la seconde guerre
mondiale et ils en ont pas un très beau
soutenir mais on peut en discuter
merci en tout cas pablo serving d'avoir
été mon invité pendant toute cette
émission aux origines de la catastrophe
c'est votre nouveau livre avec raphaël
stevens qui est sorti aux éditions les
liens qui libèrent
merci encore merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez si frédéric roig un numéro
[Musique]
où